[Music]
just in the UK who's not giving up so
let's say the UK not the UK who just
from here Dives underneath leaves their
feet there not
that the UK who is not giving up
eventually you're going to feel this uh
ground coming energy coming back
up that's the part boom right there that
you poke you down so he goes down not
because I'm shoving him down
he goes down because that energy gets
redirected boom down to the ground
that's why it's percussive this would be
different you can see that's different
prussing pop right there I want you to
just feel that boom right
there pop right
there okay let's go okay so part of that
energy is being taken off as well
externally by the rotation so when he
when he gets that leg back underneath
him and he tries to raise it's not that
I Coke you back into his leg I Coke you
back into the spir do you understand
okay so I'm going to continue that but
I'm actually going to yield the entire
time when you yield when you felt where
you would have C youed that's where
you're going to let that go and let it
come into your armpit area
so around there it is right there down
right and you're in Roo
okay just
like okay same foot
position same eal hand your fingers go
up towards his head you can of course
attack the wrist
there some mistakes don't lay on him
it's not a shoulder
pin it's elbow it goes into the elbow so
tap when you don't like it you
understand so don't lay on him you're
here and to attack the elbow you drive
your hips in
boom
[Music]
let's go resist the
temptation to lean on
him I'm never going to get that dude
down he's too strong so I go on the
elbow
so do not disengage your Center and
start laying on him you're going to fall
almost like Sumi was on the elbow not on
him boom elbows just on the elbow you
see my body's this way not this way this
way I'm attacking the
elbow just like hold up
elbow not this
way
elbow on the
elbow
elbow let's go